foreign
[Music]
thank you very much
um so yeah my name is Lydia as akinfenu
I just finished my PhD at Northeastern
University
and I'm just starting here as a foxy
pasta postdoc at the ml pod
um so we'll start with just a high level
um idea of what the area is that I like
to do research in and then I'll talk to
you about a specific problem that I like
um so very abstract high level uh
pipeline of machine learning algorithms
we have some population D that your data
come from you draw a specific training
data set of end data points X from that
population you give it to your algorithm
and you want to get out a model w
and you know this model could do many
things it could be uh you wanted for
prediction you could want it for
inference for example you want to learn
the mean of that population D but in any
case what you want to do is to learn
something that's accurate for D and
you're using X only as a proxy
the problem is that many natural
analyzes and machine learning algorithms
um overly tailor their outputs to the
specific training data set they have in
their input and what I mean by that
umbrella term is could manifest itself
in several behaviors for example the
output could be very brittle to small
changes in the input or it could be that
the output is only accurate for X the
input that it has and it says nothing
about the population D so essentially
it's learning patterns that exist by
chance in X and it's not learning
anything about the population
and overall this kind of means that
machine learning algorithms are not
naturally guaranteed to perform as we
expect them to
and so theoretical foundations of
machine learning I think that's the
great thing that they bring in that's
formal stability conditions
that
um describe formerly these uh unwanted
behaviors
and can provide tools to satisfy the
stability conditions to avoid these
unwanted behaviors or Reason about them
and
so the bulk of my work has been focused
on one specific stability condition
that's differential privacy
and uh at its core it is a stability
condition it says that the output
shouldn't change too much if you change
one person's data point in the input
and I've worked a lot on differentially
private learning and statistics and I've
also worked on
um reasoning about stability conditions
that imply generalization that is the
performance of the algorithm in the
training data set is close is a good
indication of its performance to the
population
um
what I most seem to enjoy about these
things is actually making connections
between stability Notions and I think
that first of all gives us good insight
about the concepts themselves but also
it allows us to import results or
techniques from one area of research to
another
and so the problem
that I'll tell you about today does has
this feel to it
um I'm gonna talk about this paper
called from robustness to privacy and
back which was published at icml and is
joined work with hilal ASI and Jonathan
almond
so
back to this machine learning pipeline
it would be helpful to think that what
we want to learn is this parameter mu
which is the mean of the population d
so again we want our output to be
accurate where Alpha is the accuracy
parameter let's say in euclidean
distance
um
and so the two desiderata that we're
going to consider is again differential
privacy and robustness
uh two conditions that have somewhat
separate bodies of research and
literature
um differential privacy was introduced
as a stability condition so that the
output of the algorithm doesn't leak too
much information about the input
robustness was introduced
um to make sure that even if the
population D is slightly specified or if
someone corrupts a part of your data set
your algorithm still gives you something
accurate
and so we'll formally Define these two
conditions uh in a moment and we'll talk
about the connection between the two
Financial privacy
says that if I change one input one
entry
um in my data set then the distribution
over the outputs of the algorithm
shouldn't change too much and more
formally Epsilon differential privacy
where Epsilon you can think of as a
small constant says that for any
neighboring data sets x and x Prime the
differ in a single point the probability
that I see any one output under X is at
most even to the Epsilon times the
probability that I see the same output
under X Prime
so worst case pairs of data sets quite a
strong conditions condition because the
distributions over the outputs are Point
wise close
robustness on the other hand is a more
average case accuracy condition it says
that you can draw a data set from a
population D so you can assume that you
have a well-behaved data set overall
and
um even if you corrupt a Tau fraction of
points in that data set then the output
of your algorithm should still be
somewhat accurate with respect to the
population d
so
we say that the algorithm is Tau robust
with accuracy Alpha and think of it as a
we think of it as a function of the
fraction of Corruptions
um if with high probability over the
randomness of the data set and the
random coins of the algorithm
um the output of the algorithm on the
corrupted data set is still accurate up
to Alpha of Tau
different conditions
um but on a higher level intuitively
kind of close since they require that
the algorithm is in some sense
insensitive to changes in its input
what we knew so far
was that uh 14 years ago
um
it working late notice that differential
privacy is actually kind of stronger it
says the end that comes out of the fact
that Epsilon differentially private
algorithms are also inherently robust to
changing one over Epsilon n fraction of
points in your input
but in the other way around we didn't
know that much we don't have a formal
connection between the two Notions
uh what we did notice
um is that you know people who work in
differential privacy uh it's very often
especially in recent years that we try
to solve differentially private
statistical tasks and to do that we try
to come up with a robust estimator and
everyone comes up with their own ideas
to sort of privatize this estimator this
is not a formal uh connection there's
just an observation about this area of
research so differentially private
statistics optimal differentially
private statistics have come up from
people thinking about the equivalent
problem in robust statistics and coming
up with their own ideas complicated
ideas to privatize the statistic
and so a natural question is can we
always do that
um
and what we do in this paper is we give
a general Black Box reduction from any
robust algorithm to a differentially
private algorithm
um
so a bit more formally
um let's think that we want to solve we
have a distribution B and we want to
find the parameter mu the mean of that
distribution which lives in D dimensions
and it leaves in an r a ball of radius r
if you have a black box access to a
robust a tower robust estimator of mu
that has accuracy Alpha of Tau with high
probability
then I can always come up with a
differentially private estimator Epsilon
differentially private algorithm for the
same problem
and not only that but I can tell you
that the error of that differentially
private algorithm
will be the error of the robust
estimator for a prescribed number of
Corruptions
and that number of Corruptions is
diligar over Epsilon n
so we can always have a differential
private algorithm with from a black box
access to a robust one
and that's how the errors between the
two algorithms would relate
what is oh sorry and I wanted to mention
this black horse reduction also came up
in joint uh sorry in concurrent work
independently
um where the authors had a slightly
different
direction in mind but I'm happy to
explain the differences offline
so what does this tell us this reduction
first of all it tells us a conceptual
thing it connects the two Notions
for low dimensional tasks so essentially
it tells us that for low dimensional
tasks where D is a constant
the cost the Minimax error of any
algorithm that satisfies Epsilon
differential privacy for a specific task
and the Minimax error of satisfying
robustness to log n over Epsilon n
uh Corruptions is the same
so that's the cost the error of any
algorithm that satisfies either Epsilon
differential privacy or robustness to
log n over Epsilon endpoints so the two
concepts are equivalent with this
relationship
right for a specific family
distributions and the same task
then this is uh true whatever is
specifically for every yeah parameter
distribution in a family you can think
for every
gaussian distribution with identity
covariance all the tasks that you know
you want to learn the mean of that
distribution
doing that under Epsilon differential
privacy and robustness to Logan over
Epsilon and Corruptions has the same
error a specific
Ally oh you can do several tasks and
so
actually one thing uh I want to mention
now is
one thing I'm
kind of like more I'm thinking about and
I want to think about in the next few
months is
what is the actual
equivalence when it comes to high
Dimensions so
um you know we have the sandwich here
that gives us this equivalence in low
Dimensions
um but really can we characterize the
relationship between robustness and
privacy in high Dimensions as well
and I think the answer is quite more
nuanced it's not exactly D but it is
closer to that side of the of the
inequality
so the relationship should be somewhat
that episode privacy and Vlog n or
whatever else and then robustness is
equivalent but I think um it's um it's
kind of there's a lot of details in that
that needs to be working
um but that's one thing I want to think
about so you want to know about yeah I
want to lower around I want to say that
yeah
any uh
any extra differentially private
algorithm has error at least the robust
error for the U of n over but it's not
the exactly it's another hacking or
something quantitative
curious
see
but I I wanted to mention that yeah in
there's several tasks for which the good
thing about this information in a more
practical sense is that it lets you
import results from robustness as they
are so we come up with optimal
estimators under absolute differential
privacy just by taking the optimal
robust estimators for that problem in
high dimensions and taking them through
our transformation we get sometimes new
results but always near optimal for
differentially private statistics
um
this is it
[Applause]
questions
uh thank you can you take
um
the ideas underlying the reduction and
maybe different Notions of robustness
that have been considered from this and
get from that like different Notions of
privacy that somehow they induce I'd
love to think about that I'm very
curious about
um I'm currently also thinking of
different Notions of robustness that in
some sense could uh be to the Limit the
same as privacy
um but uh this reduction specifically is
kind of very tied to the fact that you
can adversarially change a fraction of
points and
um it doesn't tailor to other types of
robustness that are usually used that
you know you you can perturb every point
you know these L2 LP Norm robustness
types of definitions
but I think it's a very interesting
question
very interesting work
um
okay you said if you if someone want to
ask questions about the difference I I
want to ask for the following reason I
remember that paper that had lots of
SOA stuff they had
volumetric volume sampling stuff uh
initially when you saw the bound I
assume that you take that D because it
was like a black box uh thing and I was
so let me ask two questions do they have
similar uh the uh so do they do they pay
the the same thing in the dimension also
the other stuff also the other paper and
the other question is like
can we somehow characterize some extra
elements in an algorithm that even if I
have this reduction I will not pay that
D for example that is my question
these are good questions okay
first of all yes the Black Box reduction
reduction is the same for both papers
um
the thing that Sam and like Hopkins that
I'll do is
this is in general computationally
inefficient
um what they do is if you assume that a
robust is an SOS can be described as a
sum of squares program then you can do
uh things in polynomial time
just make the reduction efficient you
can make the reduction efficient under
certain SOS assumptions yeah
um but in general you can't avoid D here
because we're using this
for let's say gaussian mean estimation
where the optimal solution should have
this D logar there so in general the
reduction itself can't have a better
dependence on D
but if you make assumptions on for
example
sparsity assumptions on the mean then
the this D would be K log d
so it's not for now assumptions about
the robust algorithm I don't know about
assumptions about the robust algorithm
but definitely if you make assumptions
about the problem
then you get a better dependence
um
I see thanks yeah
thanks
thank you
[Applause]